hey guys it's justine and today we're
doing a follow-up video to my s10 plus
unboxing review
and my day with the s10 plus and we've
got a new little friend here this is the
s10e
i'm sure you guys have seen a bunch of
videos and i've also watched a bunch of
videos covering both of these phones and
there's been so many great reviews of
the s10e
that i needed to check it out for myself
a huge thank you to metro by t-mobile
for partnering with me on this video
i've been on the network since my trip
to new york last year and since then
their network has been there for me on
the road through all my travels
and again through these upcoming few
weeks where i'll be traveling some more
this is also really exciting and such a
perfect fit for this video because metro
now has some of the samsung galaxy s10
phones in their lineup it's really great
that metro has these flagship devices
because these tend to be a little
expensive but you'll be saving so much
with your metro plan that it ends up
paying for itself you can get an
unlimited high speed data plan for four
lines for thirty dollars per line
so now it's time to unbox set up and
take these guys outside
this is the prism white
it's so beautiful
like i thought that i was really into
the ceramic
but look at this i'm not sure if you can
tell
but it's so pretty and just like in the
previous unboxing
we've got all of the same goodies
charging brick dongle
usb whoa hello and now for the s10
i'm so excited about this little phone
it's crazy how powerful this thing still
is
oh you're so i'm so excited it actually
matches my outfit
it matches perfectly like look at that i
accessorize my phones to my outfits
the s10e comes in two different
configurations there's the six gigs of
ram with 128 gigs of storage
and the eight gigs of ram with 256 gigs
of storage
the battery life on the s10 is 3100
milliamps whereas
the s10 plus is 4 100 milliamps both of
these phones can take an sd card so you
can expand the storage up to 512 gigs
which i feel like is a lot of storage
especially because i feel like most
people storm things on the clouds now
the clouds multiple clouds
and on the front you'll notice that the
s10e only has one camera and the s2 plus
has two so the two cameras on the front
of the s10 plus one is actually just for
depth so you'll be able to get better
portrait mode photos
and the s10 only has one obviously the
sn plus has a much bigger screen
this is a 6.4 inch amoled display and
the s10e
is only a 5.8 inch let's look at the
terms and conditions
we're looking we're looking okay okay
the fingerprint sensor in the s10 is
actually located
on the power button which i almost like
this placement better than the in-screen
fingerprint reader because i feel like
when i'm picking up my phone like i'm
just gonna go like this anyway i know
some of you are probably wondering
about my s10 plus fingerprint dilemma
that i was having and then i did
the update that samsung had and it
worked so much better i also ended up
adding
several of my fingerprints so since then
things have been working out quite well
i'm not gonna lie i think i actually
like this
placement better now that both of my
phones are set up i'm gonna take these
guys out and take them for a little test
i really like this prism white it's like
so pretty it's super holographic
one of the other cool things is you can
wirelessly share power
which is so freaking cool i showed you
guys this in my previous review
but i just need to share with you again
do you need to charge your phone well
you can charge your phone
with my phone
you can also charge anything that's chi
wireless compatible so you can even
charge your airpods which is
insane if not the new airpods that is
we've got both of our phones set up
we've got the s10e the s10 plus
i just can't get over this prism it's a
beautiful holographic look now we have
to set up our little rig here so the way
that i usually do this is i just get
this little tripod and then i put this
little
mounting bracket on and these are the
little mobile
clamps that you just put your phone in
super easy this is what i use for all of
my videos whenever i'm doing cell phone
tests
what's great is if i put them this way
then both of the lenses are sort of
in a very similar location one of my
favorite features on these phones is the
ultra wide angle lens like
look at this it's incredible one thing i
will say though is you can definitely
tell that the image stabilization
is not a thing in the video because it
is a little bit shaky but i'm gonna do a
quick little test here
so there's tyler hi yeah this
this looks great cool so we're gonna
zoom in
okay one we go so there's regular the
one thing
the s10 plus has that the s10 doesn't
have is the telephoto lens
so i'm super zoomed am i super zoomed i
can't see myself super
super zoom it's a little too
zoomed for comfort and now here's what
it looks like with a wide-angle lens
this is so great i'm having a lovely
time if you guys can't tell
i love doing phone review videos i think
they're probably one of my favorite
things to do
favorite things to shoot and then when i
start editing and realize all this
footage that i have
that's when i start questioning my
decision why would i decide to do this
look how long my arm is you can't tell
how long my arm is
but it's so long it feels like i feel
like i'm stretch armstrong
i made that joke already in my previous
video so i'm gonna reuse it if you guys
didn't see it
we're gonna test out the front-facing
cameras here testing both of these out
the lighting in here it looks incredible
in these phones
move it around a little bit
so yeah see how the stabilization is
i can't wait to take this outside and
feel maddie that's my dog do you guys
have a dog have you seen a picture of
him yet i post
a lot of my dog so both of these phones
do
have a wide angle front facing camera
but what the s10 plus has that the s10e
doesn't have
is the second camera which is used for
depth sensing so technically it's a
camera
but it doesn't actually take a picture
you guys know that i take a lot of
photos and videos
so one of the things that i'm thankful
for with metro is their unlimited data
their fast upload speeds
and their wide range of nationwide
coverage i'm always traveling so just
knowing that i'm able to post and give
you guys all the updates of like what
coffee i'm drinking is super important
to me and i know it's super important to
you right now i'm actually not drinking
a coffee i'm drinking yerba mate
but you would know that if you're
following me on instagram i was just
taking some selfies here in the live
focus they actually look pretty good
it's great when you're outside because
the whoa jeez
so absolutely
neddy come here it was just post mates
it's just postmates i know i get excited
as well
who's a good boy who's the best boy
oh my gosh the wide angle looks so crazy
can you believe those are our legs when
we order
food we make sure that we give the dog
like something too he's smiling
of course he's smiling you're smiling
i'm not camera ready
she's not camera ready okay you're out
of focus
pot yeah good boy pot
look at that foot good foot
see if we can get a live focus pup i
gotta give him a treat okay yes
look at all of our feet in this wide
angle
sit up up up
sit way down
sit here you go here's your close mates
the wide angle looks so good i got so
many cute pictures of maddie
another great thing is google one is
included in select unlimited plans on
metro so all of your photos and videos
are automatically backed up which
honestly is so important because
like look at this like look at this
little baby boy
this needs to be protected and saved hi
jenna hello
thanks for joining me for this lovely
lunch she said there's going to be
shopping and food
i did but we're gonna talk about our
phones first so take a picture i'll do
live focus oh you're cute
oh my gosh the wide angle is so crazy
now take some pictures of me but with
this yeah so that's the s10 plus that's
the prism white it looks so good look at
it
that's a cool color i love it wow spicy
i see tyler in the background
i'm gonna do a live focus now did you
know that live focus is actually my
favorite feature
it is pretty cool i know that's my
oh look well you know this is like my
second review
oh look we're doing a comparison also
with the
s10 plus with the s10e but look how
pretty this blue is
these are really cool colors i would get
this one yeah i really like it i like
the blue though a lot
so i've also been shopping for things
for my new office
jenna has been there through the
beginnings the middles and then the
starting overs of my office
like it's been so crazy like we
basically just like ripped everything
apart and completely started over
so i've been doing some shopping of
course on amazon with your metro plan
you actually get an amazon prime
subscription so you can watch movies and
shop and
amazon prime is honestly how i survive
insane do you want to see this
table that i'm looking at i don't know
if you'll like it or not but i'm into it
i thought you meant that you were
looking at this table like showing them
amazon i'm talking to you
that one oh i like that one that one
that one's a little expensive it doesn't
even actually look that nice
so what do you think so far i love it
look how crisp this uh the selfie looks
really cool really good you actually
look really pretty i'm not i'm not that
you don't write it anyway
but it's a really good fixture so this
is mine right especially after that
insult this is my phone now
no but if you do switch to metro you can
save a ton of money so i guess
essentially
you could buy it so my favorite thing on
the s10e is this is actually where the
fingerprint reader no
way yes i love it so much like i was
really into having the in-screen
fingerprint reader
but after using this one for like a day
i am so
into it wait because that's usually
where your hand goes i know
i see what you're doing there hey do you
want me to charge your phone watch this
have you seen this yet have you seen
powershare let me blow your small simple
mind
i have but i'll i'll yes but just but i
have no idea
you know what i don't think i'd want to
use this feature with you because you'd
always be selling my juice
i would but it is good to have i like
that you know who would actually always
use this brienne
sister we'll plug it in bring a mophie
that's really cool though in case of
emergencies i'm into that
all right well let's finish our drinks
and our snacks and
i don't know what's like my picture i
want to be beautiful okay one more
picture one more picture
thank you guys so much for watching and
a huge thank you again to metro by
t-mobile for partnering with me on this
video it really is
amazing to see how much you can actually
save by being on the network i will see
you guys in my next video let me know if
there's anything else you guys would
like to see here on my channel and until
then
i'll see you later
[Music]
you